[Applause]
[Music]
Ecuador with just over 283 000 square
kilometers that's 109 000 square miles
is one of the smallest countries in
South America despite this in recent
years the storms of its political
climate have become real Cyclones
Ecuador has become a country that just
keeps on generating more and more
political Blockbusters with our own
particular dose of conspiracy public
revolts and even Exiles and
international persecutions the latest a
president who has staked his capital and
his political plan on a referendum that
has now left him completely knocked out
Solutions
with the parliament against him the
current president lasso tried to bypass
The Ledger and move forward with his
government program by directly seeking
popular support he did it by means of a
referendum to modify the Constitution
you all know that England America
Constitutions are never set in stone
they're basically cut and paste
and so on the 5th of February 2023
ecuadorians were summoned to the polls
to choose Municipal political
possessions but also to declare their
oppositions on eight constitutional
reforms promoted by lasso and of course
also by extension to show their support
or rejection of his government it was an
All or Nothing gamble on the part of a
desperate government that had found
itself cornered and blocked however
things could not have turned out worse
for them the president not only lost the
referendum but also the little amount of
political Capital he had left now how
did it come to this point how could the
president of Ecuador launch such an
ordeal are we on the verge of the return
of Rafael Carrera and hard-line
socialism and perhaps the most important
question what exactly is going on with
Ecuador well in this video we're going
to answer all of these questions but
first we have to understand how they've
reached this point so let's look look at
some history
[Music]
Lenin Alesso the elves of change
let's do a little rewind about a year
ago here on visualpolitik we told you in
this video how Lennon Moreno had turned
his back on the socialism of the 21st
century and how he had completely
disassociated himself from his
predecessor Rafael Carrera under
Moreno's Administration among other
things another constitutional referendum
was promoted to prohibit presidential
re-election and disqualified persons
convicted of corruption from holding any
public office in addition during his
term of office a major adjustment in
government spending was carried out to
reduce the fiscal deficit I'm sure many
of you may remember how this whole story
ended
[Music]
in any case Moreno managed to survive
the political catastrophe he managed to
negotiate a truth with the Confederation
in the gainer in exchange for a much
much more gradual adjustment plan so
gradual that it came to practically
nothing and so we reached the month of
April 2021 when the second round of
presidential elections was held and this
time Ecuadorian said enough was enough
they voted for a renowned businessman
and Banker who'd already been a
presidential candidate in 2013 and 2017.
they did so to leave behind the hard
socialism of Raphael carrera's
supporters we sincerely believed we were
winning but our projections were wrong
Rafael Correa 11th of April 2021 thus
began a new era a new stage that in
theory meant a complete change of course
lasso was commissioned to build a new
Ecuador but is he really doing that
let's find out
lasso third time's the charm
[Music]
Guillermo Albertos and Diego lasso
Mendoza is not exactly a new face quite
the country he is an old acquaintance of
the Ecuadorian establishment lasso comes
from a middle-income family he's the
youngest of 11 siblings and at the age
of 15 he had to start working while
still attending high school he did not
just do it however in any job he started
working as an office boy and a count
assistant in some of the financial
entities of the stock exchange and his
hometown gayak wheel it was there that
he became acquainted with the economy
and particularly with the banking sector
it was something like the first step in
a career straight out of a Hollywood
movie a real example of the social
elevator in practice
foreign
1993 he completed an MBA and by the end
of that same decade he came to lead the
association of private Banks of Ecuador
between 1994 and 2012 except for some
short periods of time he was the
president of Banco gaiaquil perhaps
thanks to that experience in August 1999
lasso was appointed super minister of
the economy but his lack of mutual
understanding with President Jamil muad
forced his resignation only a month
later Ecuador at that time was an
absolute disaster the country was facing
an economic meltdown marked by a 12
fiscal deficit a moratorium on foreign
debt an uncontrolled inflation it was an
explosive context that ended with the
dollarization of the economy
fortunately for him lasso's resignation
somehow kept him out of the cataclysm
which allowed him to enter the political
arena in 2012 and run for the presidency
itself of course this process would take
time specifically he had to make three
attempts until he finally hit the
bullseye in 2021 Ecuador handed over the
leadership of the country to Guillermo
lasso
the idea at that time seemed to be very
clear to bury carrera's policies once
and for all and to seek economic
reactivation through two methods a tax
reform and a labor reform is
however visual politic Community there
are some things that are easier to
promise than to actually do and guess
what this is precisely a good example of
this check this out
[Music]
a mortgaged legitimacy with
parliamentary paralysis
[Music]
in the 24th of May 2021 in the midst of
an economy decimated by the pandemic the
new government took office however the
main concern was not that but the
governor's problems with the presidency
that were already coming to light you
see in Ecuador the legislative elections
coincide with the first round of
presidential elections an election in
which lasso barely obtained
approximately 20 of the votes this meant
that despite his victory the National
Assembly remained on the verge of being
controlled by the opposition something
that ended up happening precisely
because of a failed move by the
governing party itself to add votes in
the second round Guillermo lasso relied
on the social Christian party he reached
the legislative agreement that granted
the party presidency of the future
Parliament
however on the 14th of May 2021 only 10
days before the inauguration the social
Christians broke their alliance with
lasso why well because the president's
party the cereo movement would not
support the election of a candidate they
had presented to president over the
Ecuadorian legislature the deputies of
the incoming government prepared to
support the candidacy of pachakutik of
indigenous orientation with the idea of
building bridges with a sector that
could be key for future reforms the
problem is that with this move they lost
the possibility of comfortably managing
the National Assembly the president's
party only has 28 of the 137 deputies
that make up this Parliament
so what was the result of this an
absolute inability to make any
significant changes the assembly is not
with lasso
[Music]
let's just say that the government has
given up any possibility of being able
to do anything with this assembly for
example during the first year of the
legislature that is between May 2021 and
may 2022 the National Assembly passed 14
laws of those 14 laws 13 were bills that
had been introduced in the previous
legislature and don't think that since
then things have improved not at all the
disconnect between the legislators and
the executive is total and guess what
the president himself couldn't have made
it any clearer check this out yes
pay attention to the statement to govern
without considering that the National
Assembly exists this is the key to
everything that follows
[Music]
bling like Houdini
and to account the absence of
legislative support and an electoral
victory that largely came about thanks
to a pact with the party with which he
is completely broken it is evident that
lasso is Shackled hand and foot when it
comes to pushing far-reaching reforms
for example in 2021 at the beginning of
his mandate the new government presented
an opportunity creation act a kind of
Mega law that aspired to bring forward a
large package of changes this did not
set well in the assembly so they forced
the government to split this kind of
megalore into two different projects on
the one hand a tax reform and on the
other hand a labor reform the first one
which had been agreed with the IMF went
ahead and came into effect in November
2021. in general terms it involved a
considerable raise in taxes with the aim
of increasing revenues by almost 2
billion US Dollars which meant raising
almost 20 percent more in one blue an
objective of that as you can see on the
screen is being achieved to perfection
in the meantime there has been nothing
but rumors about the labor reform in
fact the tax reform actually went
through basically because legislators
could not agree on presenting a common
front against the newly elected
government well because of that and
because tax hikes are not particularly
popular in the first place but on the
other issue on the labor matter the
reaction was much more forceful Nothing
Was Heard again and keep in mind we are
talking about a country where informal
work in the labor market affects almost
three quarters of all employees in the
country so naturally you can already get
an idea of what the wages are like
[Music]
in fact the assembly's reticence towards
the government even made it difficult to
pass the integral security law a law
that was a matter of urgency in a
country where between February 2021 and
November 2022 more than 400 inmates died
in 11 prison massacres waged between
different drug gangs in other words
dealing with the legislative branch has
become a real nightmare of course that
has not been the only problem lasso has
had to deal with Ecuador is becoming a
major hub for international narcotics
distribution
for example according to the UN it is
already the third country on the list
with the most Coker seizures in the
world in fact in April 2022 lasso had to
declare a state of emergency and deploy
10 000 police troops in the provinces of
guest manabil and esmeraldes to
counteract the intense violence
generated by drug trafficking in the
area and that's not all just two months
later the president had to do the same
in several provinces to stop a fresh
indigenous Uprising against his
government's policies
in other words between one thing and
another lasso's presidency has
practically turned into a never-ending
nightmare the only good news for the
president seems to be foreign policy
news lasso has received praise from
Jewel Biden so far in his term in office
while signing a free trade agreement
with China and now everything points to
the fact that the free trade agreement
with the United States may also be
forthcoming I congratulate the president
for setting a regional example on
security migration and economic progress
the United States will continue to be a
strategic partner of Ecuador to generate
development and opportunities in our
nation Joe Biden 20th December 2022 but
beyond that between the violence the
indigenous uprisings and the total clash
with the assembly the president's
mandate seems to be out of steam at
least without room for any maneuver and
it is right at this point when in an
attempt to regain political initiative
lasso decided to go all in
[Music]
the finalist shipwreck
with everything going against him and
with many analysts considering his
mandate to be exhausted and considered a
failure Guillermo lasso decided to throw
himself to the mercy of The Ballot Box
he did so with only between 20 and 30
percent of popular approval however both
the president and his cabinet consider
that if the questions were correctly
focused that yes vote could win easily
so they jumped into an empty pool
referendum
foreign
idea was brilliant in some ways if it
worked propose a constitutional reform
on initiatives promoted by the
government itself during the previous
year so the victory of the yes vote
would serve as a sign of popular support
for its Administration this is similar
to what Luis La calpo did in Uruguay in
March 2022
thank you
however in the case of Ecuador the
reforms proposed referred to eight more
or less significant reforms in summary
they are this allow the extradition of
ecuadorians linked to organized crane
guarantee the autonomy of the State
Attorney General's office reduce the
number of deputies in Parliament reduced
the official number of political parties
change the composition of and return to
the assembly part of the competencies of
the Council of citizen participation and
social control a body created by Carrera
and finally some changes in
Environmental Conservation policy such
as the recognition of compensation
repayments no major changes but mostly
more arrests reasonable reforms that in
theory were capable of achieving broad
popular support
lasso gambled everything on one card
even when the risk was not exactly small
without legislative support with the
criminal gangs emboldened and the
legitimacy of origin questioned the pro
career parties and the various
indigenous movements threw themselves
against the reforms advocating and
campaigning for the new the final
outcome was not only a torpedo aimed
directly at the ship on which the
government sails but may even result in
The Rebirth of careerism in the country
the eight public referendum points were
rejected by the population with an
average of 56 percent of the negative
vote
and not only that along with these
results the candidate supported by
Raphael Carrera also triumphed in the
major districts of the country remember
that these elections also included the
election of local authorities where the
Carreras party obtained a majority of
votes in Quito and gayakuil and at this
point president lasso seems to be
cornered on all fronts A legislature
absolutely against him a citizenry
dissatisfied with his mandate and now to
top it all off multiple jurisdictions
governed by his opponents the question
then is what can we expect for the rest
of his term well given that what we have
seen not much or rather nothing at all
any other outcome would be surprising
given the political situation in the
country at this point lasso's government
seems to be easy prey for opposition
parties indigenous organizations and the
political reforms against him if he
wants to keep a Lifeline until the
formal end of his term lasso is going to
have to negotiate an above all give in
however even that may not be enough
because Raphael carrera's name is back
on the table we achieved The Impossible
we are once again the citizens
Revolution Raphael Korea whatever the
case a new phase is now beginning but at
this point the questions are over to you
do you think we will see Rafael Carrera
again at the helm of Ecuador what has
gone wrong with lasso and are we
witnessing the end of his government you
can leverage your answers in the
comments below and let's open a
respectful debate of course if you found
this video interesting don't forget to
like it so we know and subscribe to all
of us here at visualpolitik thank you
all once again very much for watching
all the best and I'll see you next time
[Music]